you might want to figure out how you
would define competence and so there's a
psychometric answer to that psychometric
psychometricians or psychologists who
are particularly interested in
measurement and then also in measurement
and prediction and so one of the things
you want to predict are the various
human outcomes like like economic
success let's say or or or subjective
well-being which is something that sam
Harris is quite excited about and a
general quality of life these things are
hard to measure but you can measure
economic success um
what and what you find is that
well there are a variety of features
that predict economic success in the
Western world then the most outstanding
of those are IQ so that's straight
intelligence and intelligence is
something like processing speed and
working memory capacity so it's the
ability to manipulate variables a number
of variables simultaneously at
relatively high speeds that's and
they're abstract variables and that's uh
that you know there's still people who
debate about the existence of IQ but
they're called fools fundamentally
because all right look I mean there's
there's absolutely no doubt that IQ is
the most documented phenomena in the
social sciences except for one thing
there's one only one thing I've ever
seen that that is being measured more
powerfully and accurately and that was
the correlation between inequality
across counties in the United States and
male homicide rate because that
correlation is about 0.9 and you
net-like that's just you never see that
the correlation between IQ and success
depending on any measure at academic
success learning speed economic success
success as a manager and administrator
success as an entrepreneurial
entrepreneur or creative agent the
correlation between that and IQ is about
0.5 which is about
time's roughly speaking
three times two to three times as
powerful as the most typical next
powerful order of effects that social
scientists measure so IQs a walloping
effect so IQs the first one hardly
surprising I mean dude especially as the
environment gets more complex because IQ
predicts performance in complex jobs
better than it predicts performance and
simple jobs and a simple job is one
where you learn it and then you repeat
what you've learned whereas a complex
job is a job that changes every day so I
suspect most of you know in the audience
have complex job and performance well I
suspect so you know it may be
performance with complex thinking yeah
well as long as the environment that
you're that you're operating in changes
on a relatively frequent basis then you
have to have an IQ to manage it
effectively
that's basically what I